since its inception twitch has been
responsible for creating moments that
will remember forever so listen
[Music]
I'm gonna hide the evidence all right
drama sadness and hype all abound in the
broadcasted lives of eSports pros
streamers and even special one-offs like
twitch presents
kappa dominate sarcasm pogchamp and
trihard bring the hype and bible thump
harnesses are soro however when it comes
to humor a staple of twitch no emo
dominates so completely as long but
believe it or not well wasn't even an
official twitch global emote until
recently to find its origins we have to
go back to 2013 law actually started
life as a photograph of John
totalbiscuit bein a popular figure in
the video game community now known for
game reviews and his love of both
Starcraft and Warcraft Bane's
involvement in gaming goes back into the
distant past he's world of warcraft
video my name is totalbiscuit and i have
to fill two hours with talk and general
drivel at MLG anaheim 2013 event
photographer jonathan tae egg also known
as it's just a tank took this now famous
image of totalbiscuit the image would
come to be used on total biscuits twitch
stream as a sub emote called cynical
life however tank later claimed that the
image was used without his permission
and he issued a takedown request for the
original image in july 2014
Bane claimed tank made no attempt to
contact him before issuing the takedown
request and would have gladly paid for
Wright's tank said his issue was that
the emo was hidden behind a paywall it
was a sub emo only after all
had it been free for all to use he said
he would have had no issue now here's
where things get really interesting
while cynical laugh was gone as a sub
emote for the moment it was also added
to better twitch TV better twitch TV is
a browser add-on that enables new emote
on twitch but you only see them if you
have the add-on installed if you don't
all you see is the command you
the emails command was low and because
anyone can install bttv that meant the
emote was available to everyone so the
add-on was able to use the original
contested cynical laugh image that tank
had taken and it was through better
twitch TV that the emote and command
became popular why name it lull in the
first place though the term had begun to
gain popularity as a distortion or
variation of lol or laughing out loud
some sources suggest that it stands for
lame uncomfortable laugh which seems
pretty unlikely my favorite is that if
you say lol wall out loud it usually
sounds more like law the term lulz and
for the lulz had previously been
connected with hacking group Anonymous
and internet culture generally as early
as 2007 it meant doing something just
for the laughs or just for the hell of
it of course the media back then was a
lot less savvy to Internet culture and
so we got reports like this they attack
innocent people like an internet hate
machine but truly epic walls come from
raids and invasions branded on the
anonymous websites with an eye just like
their nationwide campaign to spoil the
new Harry Potter book ending the
connotation that Lal has implies that
you're laughing at someone or something
specific it's not really a general
laughter but more often targeted and
often with a generous amount of cynicism
perfect for the cynical brit himself
totalbiscuit
another thing that's definitely true
about lo is that it means dick in Dutch
I'm not kidding it means a big ol
one-eyed monster step right up and see
the one-eyed monster anyways
Lal had a greater destiny than simply
remaining a bttv emotes in August 2016
totalbiscuit teased cynical Lal a new
version of the emote on Twitter it
featured a stylized depiction of the
expression seen in the original
photograph thus avoiding further legal
issues with the photographer but the
real qu came on September 1st 2017 when
law was made a global emote it should
have been a big moment for the emote the
problem which used total biscuits new
2016 version of the emote and not the
law that bttv fans were used to and
because it used the same command lu l it
cost some disruption with fans
totalbiscuit explained that due to the
previous dispute with the photo twitch
wouldn't use the original and to his
credit he took some enjoyment from the
outrage offering up this new subscriber
emote that used the rallying cry of bttv
law loyalists not my law thankfully
twitch revolution was averted when the
original lull emo was reinstated as lu l
that's right
capital Elle's small U or how a
lujah and that's the story of law but
one thing that always bothered me is
whether everyone using lull in chat even
understood that it was a bttv emotes
what percentage of viewers simply
parroted law understanding and
instinctively as a form of law without
BT TV actually installed we'll never
know for sure but if you're one of those
people nice work
what the is with these endings
every week it gets worse and worse
because I is wrong with you dude
I wish I wish people could understand
that the setup is like a camera and your
face is right next to the line basically
look in the background so like I can
immediately see if I had that guy's like
there's no time no no you're like like
somebody's needling you or like bamboo
under the fingertips